it was Kazakhstan's big moment could
Almaty snatch the Winter Olympics away
from the favorite Beijing like Beijing
they put on an elaborate presentation
although the IOC remains tight-lipped
the Kazakhs plan to build a traditional
winter sports center sustainable
affordable and with plenty of snow the
budget of the games it's very efficient
and all all what mansion is budget is
related to the games we count every cent
which even we'll spend next five years
by contrast Beijing's facilities are
spread across a large area split into
three zones with the competition's 90 to
160 kilometers apart and there's not
much natural snow in either Beijing or
Almaty despite strong presentations a
question mark hovers over the candidates
cities the only two remaining after
others had withdrawn both have come
under fire for their record on human
rights
well no such question that was a raise
today but I think I do believe that by
hosting another Olympic Games it's a
great enhancement of human rights and
social progress of China as home thank
you the decision on which city will host
the Winter Olympics of 2022 will be made
at the end of July